People go to the movies to be entertained:
to laugh, to cry, to be shocked.
But sometimes, moviegoers get way more than
they expected and end up running for the door.
Here's a look at some movies that audiences
just couldn't take any more.
A Clockwork Orange
Stanley Kubrick's adaptation of Anthony Burgess'
chilling novel was instantly considered brilliant,
dangerous, and also a little maddening.
Actor Malcolm McDowell said he saw people
"walking out of screenings in droves," with
many viewers outraged by the ultra-violent
content.
Although Kubrick stood by the movie, a rash
of copycat crimes in England convinced the
studio to pull it from theaters there.
Meanwhile, it became a smash in the U.S.
After all, Americans do love to dance.
"Singing in the rain.
I'm singing, I'm singing in the rain."
Swiss Army Man
Everyone knows flatulence can clear a room,
but when Sundance Film Festival audiences
got a whiff of Swiss Army Man, it nearly emptied
the theater according to Variety.
Why?
Well, Daniel Radcliffe plays a rotting corpse
that Paul Dano's character rides like a jet
ski — propelled only by Radcliffe's, uh,
natural gas.
The movie wasn't a total stinker, though:
Critics have given it mostly favorable reviews.
"Uh, that's weird, people don't like other
peoples farts."
The Blair Witch Project
While the low budget of The Blair Witch Project
brought an exceptional financial return to
Artisan Films, it did cost a lot of viewers
their lunches.
The shaky, found footage-style camerawork
had people hitting the deck — and not necessarily
out of fear.
Many audience members walked out due to nausea
and panic attacks, while others gave up due
to the movie's slow pace.
"It's not the same log Mike."
Hey, there's nothing scarier than evil logs!
And not the poopy kind.
"Please help us"
The Exorcist
Warner Bros. marketed The Exorcist as "something
beyond comprehension" and, for a lot of theater-goers
in 1973, that was exactly right.
Thanks to word of mouth, the film became a
must-see event, but once the frames started
rolling, many people couldn't handle what
they were seeing, such as the horrifying image
of a little girl twisting her head completely
around or, well, pretty much anything else
from the movie.
Plenty of people were too grossed out or terrified
to finish the film, but others left because
they were offended by the religious implications.
Hey, some religions just don't like pea soup.
"Mmm, sacrilecious."
Reservoir Dogs
Quentin Tarantino's directorial debut established
him as a true talent, and the film's torture
scene still serves as a yardstick by which
the concept of "twisted" is measured.
The now-iconic scene was too gory for some
people, though, and it prompted many early
exits.
But Tarantino took it as a compliment.
He said:
"It never bothered me when people walked out.
It just meant the scene worked"
A little too well: famous horror make-up artist
Rick Baker left a screener during the scene,
saying he was in the business of fantasy-based
scares, and Tarantino was "dealing with real-life
violence."
Pulp Fiction
Tarantino's second movie won him an Oscar
for best screenplay, but the film wasn't universally
beloved when it came out.
The non-linear storytelling, graphic violence,
and rape scenes led to walk-outs, with Tarantino
famously being heckled during his acceptance
speech for the prestigious Palme d'Or at the
Cannes Film Festival.
And those who walked out were luckier than
some others who had to be carried out.
The scene in which John Travolta thrusts a
hypodermic needle into Uma Thurman's chest
caused multiple audience members to faint.
The Lion King
The circle of life may sound beautiful in
song, but some kids and their parents didn't
think it was so fantastic when King Mufasa
was gruesomely murdered on screen by way of
a wildebeest stampede.
"Great idea, who needs a king?"
"No king, no king, la la la la la."
Many shocked parents had to remove their horrified
children from the audience.
"Pumba, not in front of the kids."
Guess it gives a whole new meaning to the
term "Scarred for life."
Am I right Lads, or am I right Lads, Cause
the bad guy is named Scar?
Get it?
Please anyone...
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
movies were just too much for you to take…